hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to focus on the correlation between
the spy so basically the global market
and amc this is also true for gamestop
but i'm going to focus on amc and we're
going to try to understand what
discrimination can mean
in terms of margin calls and in terms of
market development for mc if the global
sell-off is to continue so let's get
into it
[Music]
all right so let's first quickly look at
the chart of amc okay that makes sense
so you guys know this charts
i was here expecting a fifth wave that
would develop in one two three four five
so this looks like a first wave
completed second wave correction
and
we are now slightly below the 61.8
percent retracement
which is around 37.5 to the eighth so
it's you know it can be tolerated you
know some access we have support at 36.5
so it's not looking bad yet we are
looking still good it's still one two
but
what is a bit worrying for me here is
that we see a positive correlation
between the global market and amc during
the two days the s p 500 crashed amc was
trading much lower as well so i want to
analyze this and i'm gonna come up here
with some answers about what can happen
if the global market sell-off is to
continue so first
quickly my analysis on the s p 500 so
spy uh tracker so basically since the
copies
crisis has started here and we had this
massive move up i can count one two
three so for me we are in the third or
maybe it's complete whatever so i see
much more upside upside right on this
market i see a higher third wave and
then a fifth wave to come so you know
maybe two fifths waves so one here then
correction then one more i mean
overall uh i am very bullish for the
long term but here what we are having
guys is not good at all so let me get
rid of this vertical line for now this
is a break up from the wedge pattern
after bearish divergence i mean
it's like everything here market making
high highs macd going lower but we had
this for already two months but only
after breakout this is a valid uh signal
so here the breakout occurred i told you
guys this is not looking good here we
had a reaction on the breakout trend
line and then we moved lower so i think
this global self will continue so this
is what i'm interested in uh
understanding what mechanisms this could
trigger so to do that i computed the
correlation between the s p 500 so spy
so that at least the closing time is the
same so it makes sense to compute the
correlation and amc so what we can see
in blue you have the correlation so the
axis of the correlation is on the left
so a correlation is always between minus
one and one one is that it's fully
correlated minus one it's like always
moving in opposite directions and in
green i added amc returns so the first
thing we can see is that this
correlation is
rather positive okay around 50
in average for the past two years so
those two stocks are correlating
positively but sometimes discrimination
is negative all right this is the one
month correlations it's it's smooth data
but you can see that even by smoothing
it we still have a negative correlation
sometimes around minus eighty percent
and each time we have a strong move up
here for example the correlation is
going down
here
this one in june 21 is not that true
we're going to analyze this but gen 21
definitely strong moves down on the
correlation so meaning s p is going
lower and amc had very massive returns
it's true as well in april 21
so this is suggesting that something is
creating buying orders a bullish
momentum an amc whatever the market is
falling so guys i think you understood
what i'm talking here about i'm talking
about margin calls that hedges need to
face to hold the short positions on amc
gme and any other meme stock that they
are showing so that's why i think that
if the global market sell off is to
continue we're going to see this
happening but for now we don't see it
the gradation is very positive and once
again each time it was like this guys
the the correction was positive and then
it was dropping and then amc was going
higher so
it can happen can still happen let me
show you something cool all right so
here guys i can add amc so we don't care
it's very small at the bottom because
the price is very different but what
we're interested in here is to see uh
what the s p 500 was doing whenever we
had those strong moves up just to
illustrate what i just showed you with
the correlation so we saw that basically
there were three moves up on amc so the
first one is here amc moving up by
300 percent and on the same day guys the
s p was down 2.5
okay
so this is an example of a day whenever
a strong move down on the snp to 2.5
right now with minus two minus two
triggered a strong move up on amc margin
calls
so it happened once
at april 20 so it's here here you can
see that even when amc was going higher
the market was going higher too so
sometimes the positive accommodation is
working too just like we had in uh june
21 you you can see that the market was
doing nothing much and amc was going
higher so the best example i have is on
in gen 21 all right this is the real
good example once again the market was
dropping two percent then 2.5 percent so
two negative consecutive days on the
market which is what is apparently
needed to trigger those margin calls so
here we had one bloody day and then
immediately we moved lower today is
another i mean yesterday tuesday session
was another bloody day and i think it's
gonna continue guys so
i'm not sure what's gonna happen to be
very honest but maybe a second negative
day would trigger some margin calls and
we would see a strong move up of amc
that could break this trend line that is
once again even if technicals are not
doing everything everything on amc it's
very helpful and many people follow this
uh technicals so if we have a breakout
above this yellow trend line there will
be a lot of buying orders for sure and
you guys know that mostly it's like the
hedge funds cutting their shop positions
that can trigger those strong moves up
and then i showed you guys already that
yesterday
or two days ago on amc the synthetic
short interest
yeah so we have right now
okay
so we have right now 19 of regular shot
interest and six percent of synthetic
short and we can go up to 17
i get this information from the option
market and like i showed you guys uh
before the big strikes with small delta
that can trigger a lot of gamma are here
so 50 60 70 so we need to go to the 50
area before uh market makers start to
buy like crazy as well so
let's see but this is a scenario that is
possible and that
would create some very high returns on
amc so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show see you guys